That’s right, it’s that time again!
We’re recalibrating, rebooting, and hitting
restart on our infamous Anom-O-Tron 6000,
the specialized supercomputer we developed
to simulate improbable scenarios between the
SCP Foundation’s various anomalies, and
any other character from any other universe
you could possibly imagine.
On today’s agenda?
What do you think would happen if John Wick,
the notorious hitman, highly trained in all
forms of combat, was up against an enemy that
won’t go down in a single shot: an undead
menace known as SCP-008?
Well, we’re about to hit the button and
find out!
Either by a pure, unpredictable instance of
human error, or through the act of some twisted
karmic fate, the SCP Foundation had an outbreak
on their hands.
A sample of the complex prion, a virus known
as SCP-008, had leaked.
The Foundation had hoped to keep the existence
of the disease highly classified, even among
its own personnel.
Their fear had been that some hostile force
would attempt to synthesize or even weaponize
SCP-008; after all, the disease had a one
hundred percent rate of both infection and
lethality.
It killed anything it came into contact with…
or at least, it killed them, to begin with.
Before long, everyone in the Foundation facility
that had been exposed to the leaking sample
or SCP-008’s already infected victims was
dead.
Flu-like symptoms were followed swiftly by
a coma.
However, the disease hijacked the bodies of
all those it had passed to, reactivating the
motor functions of their corpses and turning
them into…
well, you can already guess.
No one was safe, even the Mobile Task Force
on the scene were soon infected with SCP-008.
They had been a squad of rookies and fresh-faced
new recruits, sent in by the Foundation under
the assumption that an outbreak of this sort
should have been easy to contain…
it wasn’t.
The entire facility was soon overrun, the
bodies of Foundation researchers, security
officers and MTF troops reanimated after their
deaths, now jostling around in search of survivors
to pass SCP-008 on to.
“That should hold them!”
Doctor Alto Clef yelled, locking tight the
entrance to the watchtower.
“This really is another fine mess, Clef!”
his colleague, Doctor Gears, replied in frustration.
“Our MTF backup are all down, we could be
the last two people on site and we’re locked
in a tower with only one entry door.
Tell me, what the hell are we supposed to
do now?”
“Will you relax?”
Clef insisted.
“Don’t worry, there’s someone we can
call to get us out of this jam.”
“Don’t say ‘I know a guy’,” Gears
sighed, as his fellow researcher gave a wide
grin and reached for his cell phone.
A few moments later, and only a matter of
miles away, another phone started ringing.
Its owner, a man in a dark, all-black tailored
suit with a shadowy shirt and tie to match,
reached into his pocket and lifted his cell
phone to his ear.
“Good evening, I apologize for calling you
at this hour,” came the unmistakable voice
of Charon, the concierge of the New York Continental
Hotel.
“That’s quite alright,” replied the
suited man.
“We received a call asking for your whereabouts,
sir.”
“A job?”
the man asked in a monotone voice.
“Indeed,” Charon replied.
“Up front?”
“I’m afraid not,” the hotel’s receptionist
answered sympathetically.
“The contract is only in exchange for payment
upon completion.
The man who made the call was very insistent,
he said he will be in no position to pay until
the job is done.
But he asked for you specifically, and told
us he’d be grateful for your assistance.”
The man on the end of the line sighed.
“Where?”
“Oh, don’t worry, sir,” the friendly
concierge replied.
“We’re sending a car for you.”
At that precise moment, a yellow New York
cab pulled up to the sidewalk.
“Best of luck, Mr. Wick,” Charon said,
before hanging up the call.
Straightening his suit, the infamous hitman
John Wick climbed into the back of the taxi
as it sped off towards its destination.
Arriving at a complex upstate, far off the
beaten track, John examined his surroundings
while the car inched closer to the nearest
part of the facility.
His years of training as an assassin, under
the tutelage of the Rusk Roma, had given him
an instinctive spatial awareness, one that
came in handy in his line of work.
But even then, John couldn’t have predicted
that something would come leaping down from
above, crashing through the cab's windshield.
The car's hood buckled under the impact, fragments
of glass spraying everywhere as an arm cracked
the front window.
The thing snarled and gurgled like a wild
animal as it reached for the taxi driver,
gripping his arm.
It pulled him by the wrist, biting down, causing
him to scream in intense pain.
Meanwhile, John had already moved with lightning-fast
reflexes and sprung out of the backseat.
He hadn’t had a chance to assess the threat,
his instincts told him his best option was
to put some distance between himself and whatever
had just attacked the car.
Then, he’d be able to get a better idea
what he was dealing with.
The job description he’d been hired for
had been light on details, John’s mystery
employer only referring to it as ‘A clean-up
operation.
Sprinting towards the facility, John slammed
the door behind him.
He pulled off his belt from around his waist
and wrapped it tightly around the door handles;
it would hold, for now.
It was only when he turned around that he
saw a few clustered groups of figures shuffling
around inside the building’s atrium.
The nearest gaggle were close enough that
it was easy for John to make out their pale
skin, sunken eyes and cheeks, the unnatural
twitches and erratic movements they were making
as the creatures turned to look back at him.
“Zombies,” John Wick muttered under his
breath.
“That’s unexpected.”
The nearby trio of SCP-008 infectees looked
like they were about to make a dash towards
him, so John moved first.
He raced towards a nearby corridor, hearing
that the three zombies were already chasing
after him.
Their shambling footsteps had quickly become
an animalistic charge, their limbs only able
to move after death thanks to the virus that
they were infected with.
Turning a corner, John Wick took cover, his
shoulder pressed to the wall.
He drew his pistol from its holster underneath
his suit jacket, and stood in a battle-ready
stance.
The second he saw one of the zombie’s faces
appear around the corner, he raised his weapon
and fired, swooping around out of his hiding
place to fire another two shots.
All three hit center mass, right through the
chests.
The noise would no doubt have drawn the attention
of the other SCP-008s in the building, but
for now, the three that had been on his tail
dropped to the floor…
only to start getting back up again.
John wasn’t used to his targets standing
to their feet after he’d already fired at
them, and as the nearest of the zombies staggered
back to his level, he lifted his firearm again.
Before his finger could compress enough force
on the trigger, though, the undead abomination
took a wild, flailing swipe at him.
The SCP-008 instance knocked the weapon out
of John’s hand, causing it to clatter to
the ground while it reared back its other
arm for a second strike.
Catching the blow, John Wick displayed his
incredible reflexes and mastery of martial
arts.
He delivered a series of precise punches and
chops, deploying a combination of Brazilian
Jiu-Jitsu, Aikido, and Krav Maga to try and
knock the snarling monster down.
With each hit, he was careful to avoid the
zombie’s mouth; having seen one bite the
cab driver earlier, John had assessed that
SCP-008 could be transmitted through biting.
And he was correct.
Exposure to mucous membranes of bodily fluids
of an infected individual was what allowed
the virus to spread.
One of the other SCP-008 zombies that were
still in the process of climbing back up swiped
John’s legs out from underneath him.
The master assassin toppled over, landing
on his back with the weight of the first monster
still on top of him, while the second clawed
at his tapered suit pants.
Seconds before it could snap its teeth down
on his ankle, John pulled back his leg and
shot it back out in a devastating bicycle
kick that sent the second zombie reeling into
the third, which was still trying to get back
up after its earlier gunshot.
But, the first of the creatures were still
bearing down on him.
Mustering as much of his peak physical strength
as he needed, John Wick held the zombie at
bay, blocking it with one arm, stopping it
from getting close enough to bite him.
His eyes darted around, looking for something,
anything he could use.
That was one of John’s most enviable and
impressive skills, one that had made him so
renowned as the legend of the assassin world.
In the hands of John Wick, any ordinary, everyday
object could be a lethal weapon.
Reaching out with his other hand, John felt
his fingertips brush against something metal.
It was so close, just out of reach.
On top of him, the zombie flailed its arms,
trying to claw at him.
Lifting both legs, in a fluid, balletic motion,
John Wick kicked the creature off of him,
crawling towards the nearby object and grabbing
it, just as the zombie started to approach
again.
With a swing and a loud, metallic clang, the
heavy fire extinguisher collided with the
SCP-008 infectee’s head.
The force of the blow caused it to drop in
an instant, landing in a heap on the floor.
John waited a second to see if it would get
back up again… but it was still.
The other two zombies suddenly dashed towards
the infamous hitman, only for their prey to
duck and weave effortlessly between their
aggressive clawing swipes, bashing his makeshift
weapon against their heads like a battering
ram against a door.
All three were down, but the entire facility
was still crawling with a mass of the reanimated
monstrosities.
Calmly, John smoothed his suit and straightened
up his shirt and tie, walking with the fire
extinguisher in hand back down the corridor
towards the sounds of more SCP-008 zombies
snarling.
They were next.
The Baba Yaga would use anything he found
to take down each and every one of them, until
not one was left standing.
It didn’t matter if all he had to hand was
a fire extinguisher, or one of the fallen
security officer’s batons, or even just
a tiny pencil… nothing would make it out
of that facility alive.
He just had to go for the head.
Still trapped in the watchtower, Doctor Clef
and Doctor Gears had long since grown irritated
with each other’s company.
They had no security feeds, no way of knowing
what was going on within the overrun Foundation
facility.
For a while, the pair of researchers had been
toying with the idea of climbing out of a
window and scaling down the side of the tower,
but gave up on that plan when they realised
that they’d only be dropping back into a
horde of SCP-008 zombies.
A sudden explosion erupted from one corner
of the complex, causing Gears and Clef to
direct their attention towards it.
From their elevation, they could see the ground
below was littered with the bodies of the
SCP-008 infectees, rendered lifeless once
again by significant cranial trauma.
In short, something had been bashing the zombies
in the head… or someone.
The sound of a banging against the locked
watchtower door startled both Foundation scientists.
Instantly they thought that the zombies had
made their way up the steps and found the
two researchers; easy prey, trapped in a cage.
The heavy thud against the metal door repeated,
then there was a pause, deafening, tense silence
filling the room.
A polite knock came from the other side of
the watchtower entrance.
Cautiously, Clef approached to unlock it.
Standing in the doorway as it opened was a
single figure, panting with exhaustion but
still nowhere near beaten.
He looked out at Bright and Clef from his
dark hair, a stern expression on his face.
Neither one of the researchers could believe
he was still alive, still uninfected.
But then again, he was the one and only John
Wick… the Baba Yaga.
Now go check out“BOBA FETT VS SCP-610 THE
FLESH THAT HATES” and “SCP-076 Able VS
Chainsaw Man...Who Has The Most Lethal Weapon?”
for more epic out of universe What Ifs!